welcome everyone thank you for your
patience as we work through the
technology to get ready for their free
speakers my name is Jim Neal I'm
university librarian at columbia and i'd
like to welcome you to the second of a
series of six programs that were doing
this year looking at different aspects
of scholarly communication we've defined
scholar communication as the creation
the distribution the evaluation the use
and the archiving of new knowledge and
we're looking at it through six
different lenses over the course of this
academic year last the last session the
first session in this series are we had
Stewart Cheever from Harvard University
talking about their new open access
policy his presentation and the
discussions which followed are up and
available on the web and we're getting
word that they're actually being viewed
and used all over the world the second
session entitled final impact what
factors really matter looks at another
aspect of the work of scholars we all
know that one of the important
motivators for those who work at the
University who work in research is the
importance of the assessment of their
work peer review is one aspect of that
and factors impact factors has developed
as another important measure looking at
the quality and the use and distribution
and reuse of research and today we've
brought to columbia three extraordinary
individuals who will speak two different
aspects of impact factors and different
approaches to impact items what I'd like
to do is introduce the three panelists
then they will come out of sequence
to share their remarks well and then sit
down and spend some time talking with
you about their comments and about your
interests and questions about impact
factors of the three speakers are Marion
Collinsworth she became director of
publisher relations at thomson reuters
and eight she is responsible for her the
communications with publishers requiring
regarding the indexing coverage of
scholar publications and journal metrics
she joined me company in 2000 as the
manager of the public relations group
before that she was assistant director
of any base the National Federation of
abstracting and information services
this is an association of database
producers and information service
providers of she's been involved for
over 20 years of all aspects of academic
social and public library work his BS
from Temple in ms from the College of
Information science and technology
addressed our second speaker which is
bijan West he is an artist fellow in the
department of biology at the University
of Washington he's presently working on
his ph.d under Karl Bergstrom and Ben
Ben curve his general research focus is
mathematical biology he's interested in
network theory and its applications to a
wide range of problems in biology
including antibiotic resistance disease
evolution is quantitative a proposal by
jose has led it in vain flee to all
sorts of different research directions
including the field of the video of
metrics he is the head of developer of
eigen factor or a free website
provide the tools and resources
librarians journal editors researchers
and publishers to assess the
ever-expanding scientific literature our
third speaker Johan Bolton is a staff
researcher at the Los Alamos National
Laboratory he holds his PhD in
psychology from the university of
brussels and was an assistant professor
of computer science at Old Dominion
University his research interests or
data mining communicational social
metrics info metrics and digital
libraries he is presently the principal
investigator for the mellon Foundation
measure project which aims to expand the
set of quantitative tools available for
the assessment of scholarly impact this
is a set of it a panelist so I think of
a lot of thority a lot of experience and
a lot of insight to share we welcome
that up to Columbia
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here in New York City this boreas
fall afternoon impact factor sites in
context I was speaking with some of your
colleagues before this presentation
about the history of the Institute for
scientific information which is now
known as Thomson Reuters as of this year
and we're impact factor and metrics and
citation databases all began and it
began with an idea in 1955 Eugene
Garfield started the company and along
with his colleague Irving sure wanted to
find ways to identify the best scholarly
publications to include in the science
Citation Index the very first product
that dr. Garfield created was called
current contents which was at the time a
very novel idea it took the leading
authoritative journals of the time
copied the tables of contents and
created an alerting system for scholarly
researchers seems a little primitive in
this digital age that we live in but it
was truly quite a remarkable product and
it began of the whole concept of
citation databases dr. Garfield and dr.
sure realized that there were a core
group of journals that accounted for
most of the citations what they wanted
to be able to do is keep on top of that
core group of journals so that they
would know what to select and what to
include in the science Citation Index I
remember using these paper tools back in
the day in the 60s and the journal
citation reports which we now
have on the web were originally a part
of the science Citation Index it was a
tool that enabled the Institute for
scientific information to identify the
key and important scholarly publications
based on citation data in the 90s when
the ear of the web came along the
journal citation report was pulled out
of the science citation index and
migrated to the web and we presently
have about 10 years of impact factor
data on the web but this was the very
beginning of citation databases and the
analysis of sites to content both
forward and time and backward in time
which still remains something of a novel
and interesting way of looking at the
impact of research over time I recently
came back from the Frankfurt Book Fair
and in the publisher relations
department at thomson reuters we index
over 10,000 journals in web of science
so that's roughly about 3,000 publishers
that we deal with globally and no matter
how much they think they know about
impact factors and what it means I come
to realize in my conversations with them
that they're missing key pieces of
information routinely we get calls
almost on a daily basis from publishers
wanting to know I need an impact factor
for this journal how do I get one you
know my authors demand it they won't
publish in my journal unless I I have an
impact factor unless something happens
what is that something that happens and
I thought it important to give you a
little back
information on how we actually lead up
to the impact factor metric and what's
involved there's an actual process we
have a editorial development group back
at thomson reuters in philadelphia
office who in many ways function like a
collection development department within
a major research library they are
developing and enhancing the database
looking at various subject categories
trying to define what is the best of the
best that we might need so there are
lots of different criteria I'm going to
touch on some of these briefly just to
give you a sense of how we do what we do
a little bit of the mystery behind the
impact factor so when we're evaluating
public scholarly publications we're
looking for certain key criteria it has
to be publishing on time there's
editorial content that we're looking at
international diversity etc and I'm
going to just touch briefly on what
these mean for us timeliness is really
critical that the journal is amassing
steady flow of papers it's meeting its
publication schedule the content must be
peer reviewed this is extremely
important in one of our key criteria we
look for english-language bibliographic
information if there's funding
information in support of the research
we encourage authors to include that you
will see eventually these are bits of
metadata that we pick up and use in our
indexing process so when it comes to the
editorial content our editors and
there's a team of about over 25
individuals many of them are subject
specialists with advanced degrees many
of them also have master's degrees from
universities with library science
programs they're looking at is this
going to enhance our our database is it
going to add value does it offer a
different perspective that might enhance
scholarly discourse they look at who the
authors are are in the journal who the
editorial board members might be is the
research that's being reported global in
context is this journal coming from a
country that is underrepresented in our
database we also include regional
journals and we select the best of the
best in regional coverage then in the
course of the journal evaluation process
because we are creating a citation
database and because we're indexing all
the references at the end of every
article we have a mask this this huge
access to data that gives us all of the
cited references to the journals that we
index and the journals that we don't so
we're able to quickly see if this is a
new journal that's coming to us how is
it being cited in our universe within
the web of science and again journal
impact factors are only looking at the
universe that's containing than web of
science we also look at the self
citation rate of journals when we're
evaluating that
for selection in our web of science
product and in the web of science eighty
percent of the journals have less than
twenty percent self citation rates this
is really key and important particularly
if there are any publishers in the room
it has certainly been brought to our
attention the misuse of self citation
rates within the database in 2006 for
the release of the 2006 journal citation
report which was in fact June of 07 it
was the first time that Thomson Reuters
suppressed approximately seven journals
from being listed in the journal
citation reports because of high self
citation rates this year when we
released the 2007 journal citation
reports there were in fact nine titles
that were suppressed the first year we
were very courteous about it and we kind
of kept it quiet notified the publishers
this year we were a little bit more
discreet I've circled the notices file
within the journal citation reports and
if you click through that in the product
news section you'll see a list of some
nine titles many of whom have in excess
of ninety percent self citation rates so
these have been suppressed from the
journal citation report our feeling is
that it doesn't accurately reflect
reflect the journals true participation
in the scholarly discourse so we're
really paying attention to this and I'm
highlighting this because towards the
end of my talk I want to share with you
some information about some new
developments so once a journal is
accepted the subject categories are
selected this is very
this puts a journal it includes a
journal in the subject category along
with its peers we look at the scope of
the journal and the scope of the subject
categories and we make a fit and a
determination as to where it is best
indexed in this example for this
particular journal we've assigned it to
the science Citation Index it's in two
editions of current contents clinical
medicine as well as life sciences life
sciences is extremely competitive to be
included in that and it's also included
in biological abstracts and viruses
previews document types is probably the
trickiest part and an area where i have
my most conversations with publishers we
go through each journal that we index
and we assign and determine what counts
as an article what is editorial material
and we do this for purposes of the
impact factor calculation as you'll see
very shortly in the web science someone
can search on a particular journal and
see very clearly out of however many
records there might be in this
particular instance over 62,000
particular records for this journal the
majority of them are in fact articles so
it just gives you a sense of what is the
content like in a particular journal
researchers may be interested in this
particularly if they are looking to
submit papers so once the journal has
been accepted for coverage and it's
going to be indexed we
at least a minimum of three years of
citation data in order to calculate the
impact factor this is not the case for
those rare journals that we pick up in
its first volume which would get listed
the next year in the journal citation
report so the calculation is very simple
but yet is something that has to be
explained many times over it cites in a
given year to anything in the journal
the previous two years / the actual
articles in the drone in the former two
years the impact factor is a journal
level metric it's not an article level
metrics and it doesn't really tell you
anything about authors in the
denominator we include original research
articles review articles technical notes
many of the journals that we index are
in fact publications from scholarly
associations where they will hold annual
meetings and publish full conference
papers if we index those full conference
papers they are included in the
denominator as well so once impact
factors are published it's important to
try to keep the impact factor as a
metric in context with its subject
category and its ranking look at like
with like compare like to like I thought
the best way to demonstrate this is to
just take a look at the journal citation
report and do a search of all the
science journals that are in web of
science and included in the jcr and sort
them by impact factor and in the science
edition of the jcr the top journal has
an impact factor of 69 point zero two
six huge number ten journal is nature
its impact factor is 28.7 51 on the
other hand if you go into the social
sciences edition of the jcr you do the
very same search you're going to see
very different numbers you're going to
see that the top journal in the social
sciences edition has an impact factor of
17.4 62 and the number 10 journal 6.6 67
so what does that really tell you not a
whole lot because the impact factor
needs to be put in the context of the
subject categories in this example this
is a social science journal has an
impact factor of five point zero one
seven but it's been categorized and
placed in two different subject
categories in business and in management
so if you're thinking the top journal in
social sciences is 17 points something
so this probably doesn't look very good
in comparison but in fact it ranks
number one of 72 journals in the
business category and it ranks number
two of 81 journals in the management
category so out of context it doesn't
appear like much but in context means
everything also the discipline is very
important to consider in applied
mathematics for instance there's a
longer citation window the impact factor
is a very narrow window in
time is looking at citations in one year
to the previous two is very narrow in
mathematics it's not unusual for the
citation tale to take a lot longer so in
this instance here the top eight
journals in applied mathematics the top
number is 5.0 99 and the bottom number
eight is 1.78 for the other thing that
we've incorporated into the journal
citation report to help with the
analysis and interpretation and use of
the impact factor are such things as the
subject category summary lists where we
look at a whole subject category and we
take the aggregate data so that it makes
a little bit more sense so in this case
in applied mathematics the aggregate
impact factor is a 0.8 56 and this helps
researchers editorial board members
publishers understand where their
journal is in the context of the subject
category we also include information
about related journals and the sighting
and citing relationships what kinds of
topics are shared what are the peer
groups who is citing who if you will we
include the journal impact factor and
all of the citations and how it's
calculated along with the immediacy
index which basically means how often is
an article cited in the first year of
publication but the interesting part
that I think is often overlooked is the
journal source data that we include down
in the bottom this area here what you'll
notice is with the ratio of articles and
references to articles you'll see that
there's a large number of other items
which would be editorial comments
letters etc what are the sizable
characteristics what makes an article
and article well certainly the number of
references might be one way of looking
at that as you see in this instance the
average review has about 46 cited
references articles about 17 and the
other items have less than one usually
don't have any references at all so that
is the direction where we're headed in
terms of how we're going to determine
document types in the future we're going
to be looking more at what are the
characteristics that make an item site
oval or not there's a lot a lot of
opportunities for shall I say fun and
games a little bit with with trying to
maneuver it for instance there are
sections within journals that are called
letters well they may be letters or they
may just really be articles if they have
charts they have graphs they have
abstracts and keywords and cited
references it's likely an article so in
the process of creating the citation
database we're creating what I like to
think of as a date of soup we're
capturing all the bibliographic
information the abstract the keywords
the author names their email addresses
their addresses institutional
affiliation very important this is
another opportunity for an institution
to find out who on their staff are
publishing and where we capture the
country level at the journal and also at
the level of the author any funding
information and conference data if the
paper was presented there so this
creates just a huge full of potential
data for other metrics beyond the impact
factor and you're just a few that I
mentioned in
such things as H index and potentially a
self citation rate so coming out the end
of this quarter probably within the next
month or so maybe even less are some
enhancements that we're making to the
journal citation report which hopefully
will give researchers publishers authors
a better sense of the metric and it
chooses over time we're going to be
including a five-year impact factor for
more accurate trend analysis we are
going to be showing the journals self
sites we're including some visualization
tools and a rank and all the subject
categories and this is a mock-up this is
this is not real data but this is what
it will eventually look like within the
journal citation report will include the
regular impact factor will include a
five-year impact factor and all of the
data as you can see at the bottom which
will include the statistics for how we
came to the site's to recent items and
the number of articles the previous two
years we will be releasing this with the
2007 jcr so we'll be taking what we
released in June and enhancing it for a
rerelease I think the most interest
interesting thing will be the analysis
of the journal self sites what you see
is down at the bottom that the table
will show how many of the self cites the
journal sites are self sites and what
percentage contribute to the impact
factor calculation so in this instance
here the journals impact factor is a 1.0
33 but if you take at the self sites
it's 0.91
eight again we're including
visualization tools and if the journals
included in more than one set subject
category we're making it a whole lot
easier for you to see exactly how many
journals are in the category what the
rag of the journal is and what port
aisle in that category the journals well
thank you very much i hope if anything
what you've learned from this is to take
the impact factor it's a single journal
metric keep it in the context of which
it was intended remember that it is not
a statement about an author it is not a
statement about a particular article it
is a journal level metric from the
citation database that we create
certainly we have access to a lot of
data that we can include and create
other additional metrics for instance
users of weather science will note that
the articles will increment at the time
cited level this happens on a weekly
basis when we upload new index content
to the database the impact factor on the
other hand is just a static number thank
you very much I guess can I entertain
some questions now well genin is going
to be setting up we're also going to
reconvene as a complete panel so we can
have more discussion later as well yes
sir hi factors side on to you
because now you have to recall you know
I think at the time and I'm I'm not
completely certain another was there has
always been keen interest on the part of
publishers and researchers who published
in their journals too and particularly
for fields like mathematics and why wear
a longer citation tale would look much
better than the five-year impact factor
would look much better than a regular
two-year impact factor but but that was
I think a metric and a time frame that
Garfield felt was optimal and I think
that what will happen in the future
remains to be seen i would mentioned the
five-year impact factor at a talk that I
gave at the Frankfurt Book Fair and
publishers were very excited about it
and and would likely then use the metric
that features their journal the Basque
actually advocate libraries that went
black attention both the Eugene Hartwick
only acts as a citation data and
realizing that maybe a little short
compliment and / defective in the next
year the year after that we didn't want
to change the definition which isn't
sound then there will be no basis of
comparison and as the database is really
something to you
but that's just uh I just fine yeah the
rational decisions um well it is what it
is but certainly with the five-year
impact factor if you noticed in my what
second or third slide we have about ten
years of JC our data on the web so I
don't know what the future holds in
terms of other impact factors over a
longer period of time it could be very
interesting why don't we move to the
second speaker but first of all I want
to thank the organizers this is this is
quite an honor it's a lot of fun for me
to come talk to a group of people that
this was originally created for Ivan
factor actually started as a little side
project really like a two-week project
we thought let's try some things and
apply some of the the mathematics that
we use in network science that we're
flying in all sorts of different to
different biology problems and lo and
behold a year and a half later almost
two years now it's just growing like
crazy and it's hardly you can keep track
but first of all yeah my name is jenna
and i am from university of washington
in a biology department and wanted to
tell you about today i'm going to fly
through some of the tools that we
created item factor i'm going to show
you some of the new stuff i'm not going
to show you all the new stuff because
there's still some bugs in it but before
i do that i kind of want to give you i
want to put I did factor into context
especially in regards to this meeting
and how it relates to maybe things that
you might be using and also kind of give
you some of the underlying philosophy
that drives some of the research that we
do in the lab so and some of you may
have heard this part of the story but I
like to give it especially at an
assessment meeting like this the the
story of assessment kind of at least in
our regards to this project started in
1927 at a small College in Southern
California pomona college and librarians
were faced with problems that they face
today even worse today than they did
even back in 1927 and it didn't have
money and of course when you don't have
enough money that
forces a question a tough question for
librarians especially for those that
want include as much as possible for all
their users of the library that what
journal should we buy and what journals
not to buy well it turns out at that
College Ramona college there were two
chemists that published a pretty seminal
at the time paper in science that
provided at least one way of making
better decisions at how we should be
deciding and that's counting citations
and which deciding which journals to buy
and which which we shouldn't and at
right now that seems pretty trivial it
seems like it's of course you wouldn't
just count citations there's so many
other things that you need to take into
account but it turns out at this time it
was actually a really at the time novel
approach to it and it also turns out
that it's had a huge impact on how
science is communicated and I actually
the structure of science especially when
we look at some of the maps that we've
worked on so let's fast-forward to 1955
when Eugene Garfield came around and
since Mary Ann actually talked about a
lot of this I'm not going to go into
detail about what impact factor was but
impact factor was another big leap at
the time as a way of assessing the
journals what to buy what not to buy so
let's let's fast forward again we're
graduating faster time here 1955 now
let's come to now so where are we so we
have made some had some some some
headway in the last couple of years but
before some of these lot of the work
that's been done in different labs
unfortunately on impact factor even
though at the time was really was a
reasonable approach at first first pass
and it still is good especially when
people are comfortable with that measure
but unfortunately a lot of people are
know that it affects hiring
it affects library subscriptions you
this crab definitely knows about that it
also of course affects people outside of
the library community affects people's
promotion and tenure it affects ad
placement that's actually a huge effect
I think there was recently a paper came
out should how much money this affects
our this the the influence this has on
advertisements and journals also for
those familiar with the RIE impact
factor is a large part of the decisions
that are made their university rankings
which is important to students and so
scientists of course obsess and I've
done this joke before but I love given
it for those of her because it's it's
it's true we always get a chuckle and
editor scheme and of course publishers
negotiate and journals pander and
administrators nag and librarians cause
gross cute but I don't put those into my
library so everyone suffers and that's a
problem and so instead of serving impact
factor serving scientists unfortunately
it's been the other way around and the
tail is unfortunately wagging the dogs
so so in it instead of the the impact
factor of serving scientists it's the
other way around so any of many of
there's millions of articles about this
this is just one of literally i have
probably over a hundred and fifty
articles about this people are
comfortable with knowing so really what
this is where this is starts to be and
well what do we do what's what's how do
we better evaluate this College has to
be done what's the best way that must be
a phone
yeah I'm going this way we're going this
way so so the thing is you need to read
but on pork patty is the best way and
there's no better way I be factors
certainly does not take precedence over
reading the journals reading how you
know there's all these promotion and
tenure and it drives me crazy sitting in
on these committees that people are just
looking at numbers they're not taking I
know people are limited by time just
like this who has time for that
unfortunately but we do there is a
legitimate need for quantitative
measures so that's kind of where we come
in we like to ask questions a lot of
this kind of started with questions like
this how do we value a journal like
science or the journal like cell how do
biologists because we're biologists and
we're also we work with an economist how
did how did a site papers in economics
and vice versa also how two bundles a
lot of you bundles is a big issue and
we're actually building we almost got
the tool built for dealing with bundles
and stuff so a good metric this is
before we even started we wanted to make
sure that a good metric most in-form
first and foremost was freely available
because we think a video metrix is only
as good as its open and can be
replicated so if it can't be replicated
it's not open it really doesn't do the
community much good so we want to make
sure all the tools that we develop at
least that can be applied to all sorts
of various data sets of freely available
we also wanted to be integrated
integrated in all sorts of databases
that we have also integrated just within
the data set that we use as our first
pass was the Thompson data set wanted
like kool-aid also social natural
science and a lot of the grey literature
so one also valid across fields and this
is a tricky crook this is a tricky thing
not that we've solved this perfectly but
the method itself intrinsic in the
method allows for more better
comparisons across fields we also want
it difficult to cheat we've done a lot
of
who's the other starter of the eigen
factor has done a lot of work with game
theory and we actually talked about
these things all the time how can you
develop a measure not just eigen factor
this difficult to achieve we also want
to maximally informative so that's
that's using tools that we have from
network science and from information
theory that really get the most out of
the data that's sitting in there it
turns out these data sets are incredibly
rich there's a wealth of information in
the citation data sets in these citation
networks so i can factor is a step but
we weren't definitely want with the
first actually i've told you on this and
here's a little time well we've been to
two of these things together he actually
came up with a paper before we even
started on eigenvector centrality which
is essentially the core it's it's the
engine that drives the algorithm that we
use with eigen factor and this is very
similar to the same sort of algorithm
that Google uses to rank the web so we
know how powerful these eigenvector
centrality things are so i'll use this
term IDing vector centrale i'll explain
a little bit about it but this is one of
the key slides until then I start
getting into the fun tools last of the
conceptual stuff and the introduction
but this is this is what we've been
doing for the last I don't know maybe
almost century we have we've been
looking at a circle know we've been
actually just day if this is just a
journal and this this represents a
journal we've been just looking at the
number you know impact factors a little
different than that so there was a there
was a leak there and there are of course
it wasn't just oh we'll just divide by a
member of articles there was there was
there was more to it but the idea is
that really were just looking at this
well this is what I've infected us it
actually takes into account the rest of
the network it takes into account what
citing one and that's what made the page
and brin so rich and and and and their
algorithm so successful there are other
sorts of things that they're they're
building on it and they're changing it
all the time but they admit they of
imported many times as saying the
PageRank algorithm which is essentially
this idea of looking at hyperlinks in
the web but instead we're looking
citations and journals essentially
looking at what citing what there's
there's a lot of information it's really
it's a beautiful story to tell and
actually there's more even to learn
about that I'm sure that just the things
that we work on so another way of
looking at it I give it this way impact
factor puts the shutters on in and looks
at the numbers coming in and actually
turns out and I always so I'm giving
always the good and bad impact factor it
turns out is it really pretty good a
reasonable approximation to some of
these sorts of things is not the same
and we've done a lot of analysis and
statistic and done some statistical
analysis to show that they're not the
same and they do should give different
information but they it's a reasonable
approximation and it's a lot easier to
explain actually the night in factories
but I'm going to try to explain it a
little bit with this so again this is
just if I had more time I go into the
history of world is really one of the
where areas that it came from it was a
sociologist that was his name was bonus
H in 1972 he was interested in looking
at so uh networks of you know whose do
important people have important friends
and this sort of thing that was that was
his idea but yeah the words that we use
eigenvector centrality and applying it
to the citation data set is what we're
doing and what like Johan has proposed
so so Google like I said it's important
websites by hyperlinks instead we look
at journals and we cite so that's that's
what we're doing we're essentially
taking a citation network we're looking
at the structure of the net so it's a
model and there's there's a lot of
different ways actually the best way I'm
not going to show you is that this is
I'm doing a little experiment on you I
want to see how many questions I have
after using this old one because I'm
comparing it to this new one that I gave
it a few other places and I had less
questions I think it might be better i'm
gonna give you this one I think it's
still okay so the idea is if
to the library and you were to open some
random journal in your collections and
open some random citation follow that
open up that journal follow some random
citation do that again do that again and
if you could war do that for an infinite
amount of time in the library after
you've done your infinite walk if that's
possible you come back to me or come
back to the website we have and you say
this is how much time I spent at science
this is how long i spent the journal of
biological chemistry and if it's like
1.99 that means one point ninety-nine
percent of all the time i was there the
other way look at it is it you you would
make a pile of journals and so you're
walking around the library you get it
you came to this journals through your
random walk you put a pile and after all
your walk you look back at your piles
and you see how high the piles on so
those numbers that you'll see you hiding
factor our percentage of time it gives
you an idea how long maybe your users
would would be using certain journals
and so you can actually apply this not
just to the Thompson data set you can
actually apply it to your own
collections let's say you just have your
own little data set that you know that's
all your users are using then what you
do is you can apply it to that data set
so what you do is you go to a journal
you look at this you follow this and you
do this for it so that gives you an idea
of what where does your researcher spend
in the long run so what measures total
value I think factor there's two main
measures we have item factor and article
influence i can factor is a measure of
total value so that's the total time you
spend whereas article influence measures
a little more prestige and being less
and less first is using terms like
prestige stuff but because i've been
asked that
I'm not sure anyway for now it's the
term i'm going to use so our confluence
measures prestige essentially the eigen
factor divided by the number of arts so
it's a but it also is normalized so that
the average journal tells you is it has
a value of one so if you see let's say
an article influence of 15 it means that
journal has an article influence of like
15 times the average trip excuse me have
the average journal within the the data
set so it's easy it's more comparable
article influence is more comparable to
impact factor than I do factories so
citations in this case the I background
going forward citations from good
journals are worth more it doesn't mean
they get more but they're worth more
citations from frugal feels like
mathematics it doesn't give many
citations out they actually don't get
they don't get robbed as my eyes
pranitha return either but will say they
don't that vivid is much credit
non-scholarly publications can be ranked
because you can buy the the method
itself and I'm not going to explain it
right now but essentially you can rank
all sorts of other scholarly literature
that's never been ranked before so even
just within the Thomson dataset which is
what we use which is an incredibly clean
really well put together data set with
those journals that are is I journals
there are lots of other items in the
database to that are cited in based on I
defect remember you can rank those the
same way in a fair way so you can write
journals that have never we've had many
many people ask this like so am I in the
database can I see what I might get a
lot of times they've never seen their
item factor or ever had any ranking and
now they get at least and I infected so
another really powerful thing and this
is now starting into getting to the
Mutual's is this is that item factor is
additive so what does that mean additive
it means that you can take numbers all
the numbers of a particular set of
journals or a bundle of journals and you
can add them up and that will give you
again a measurement of the value of
bundle or that group of of journals so
if you have let's say science is two and
nature's three and sells one then you
have an eigen factor of six for the
group and that gives you six percent of
the time you expend at those particular
drugs incredibly clever because you can
do a lot of things which I'm going to
show you a couple one of them is you can
do really cool things like this this is
what you're looking at right now is a
map of science let me show you how we do
the map and we have to combine this with
the mapping but each one of those
squares represents a journal and I'm
guessing that yeah thanks if we'll turn
those lights down then we'll turn it
back up the big square can anyone guess
what that probably is the biggest square
what journal good good guess its nature
but its science is next the next
actually journal biological chemistry is
this is a good faculty member so this
isn't for value so the way it's
partitioned actually gives you an idea
of that's that's combined with the the
mapping stuff that we do so I'll explain
that more but what you can do is just
build a here real quick so you can
actually look at where ideas we say
where ideas are coming from there's more
than that but you can look at the floral
you can click on a journal let's see
it's hooked on nature and you can see
where the flow is going in one step you
can look at it two sets you can look at
after its converged you can actually
look where ideas come let's saddle if
you can see this Kiev us yeah you can
see that this is a this is economics but
what you notice about economics compared
some of these other journals they kind
of only site themselves there's all
sorts of I mean this I could give an
entire talk because we've been playing
with this for the last month and a half
two months but we've just got the
technology basically got the code the
bugs out of it um you you so many
stories are popping out of this
reference type of representation of
analyzing flow so you can you can go
over any journal and it'll tell you what
the journal is eventually what field you
can also look at the flow
the floral actually tells you something
about not only what that time step is
but actually gives you projections as to
where because they're trends a lot of
times with trends so all I can show you
more about this later if we have more
time or i can show anyone afterwards
that wants to look at that thank you for
turning up that down so something else
is cost-effectiveness and we're finding
that this tool is probably the most hit
tool that we get at least Roger is
probably the most useful for librarians
that have to take into account price
essentially there's more to it but the
basic idea is that you can take the idea
factor and you can essentially divided
by the price of that Journal that gives
you another way of valium so if we go to
the web I'm going to try this I
hopefully this works oh look alright so
you're the item factor that all real
quick
I hope to serve now that we have been
come on safety okay so there's all sorts
of cool things here but i'm just going
to show just a little bit of
cost-effectiveness so does anyone have a
particular field they want to look at
all right I don't Oh Madison okay sounds
good hey first come first serve so
medicine where how about a particular
areas in general in terminal how about
that okay okay all right so if we if we
search here if I click on ok if I cook
on it you can actually see so the purple
bar represents the amount of eigen
factor the percentage of times that you
take total in that field because we're
what you you tip that a few you start
doing the walk around in the field and
that gives you a percentage so the
purple bar represents that much the bar
in the bottom is the green you start to
get an idea of the value of a particular
or let's say you have a budget amount
and you have let's say four million
dollars to spend I'm sure we all have to
be stopped no I don't know about that
but the idea is this is just we're
actually releasing well hope we're
developing still now what this real the
tool is going to do that this is kind of
the first pass it but the idea is if you
scroll down what are you noticing
immediately you're getting a lot of your
eigen factor almost all the i/o factor
but now you're starting to increase a
lot more on price and you're not adding
that much more Ivy factory so that
actually tells you that gives you an
idea of what you can like when you
include price if you're starting to look
at bundles and there's other things that
we're doing but when you hear
cost-effectiveness again this is a one I
could give a whole talk on is this
cost-effectiveness stuff that this is
this a lot of this work comes from Ted
Bertram who's an economist at UCSB and
he's done a lot of stuff with the
economics of scientific publishing but
you can do things like click on journals
to as well and you can get trends of the
citation information we also have more
fry
updating come as well so you can look at
all this sort of information so there
are other tools and since I'm here is I
don't want to put back again I'm going
to just show you one other tool we
actually have a bunch of things we're
released by the most exciting in my
opinion we have is coming up we have
actually two or three new things coming
up we're still want to make sure we get
it all right make sure we understand the
methods and make sure there's no bugs
but it's coming out hopefully maybe in
the next we'll set three-month problem
six months or something but this is one
of the things that you can do with all
these metrics that I'm talking about so
this is a way of taking this rich all
his data that you deal with and trying
to try to pull stories out try to
understand what these are all these
variables you're hearing all these
different measures how do we represent
well that's part of the project it's not
just developing algorithms it's not just
messing around with fun things that we
like to work on it also want to develop
actual tools that can help you and this
is this is an example of one this isn't
like this is actually me through this
google docs application but what you can
do is you can you can change any of the
things that we talked about let's say
you want i can factor you can switch
things you can go i'll go back to
article influence you can actually log
things so you can actually get an idea
you get should the other is up there you
can log it and that depending on what
you're looking at and what you want to
do you can get an idea so if you play
this you can watch over time how what's
happening to these journals i did factor
the size of the circle i should mention
is Ivy factor and you can also change
that as well so what's great is you can
start to see what's happening and I'm
actually showing you
the leaf I would say the least
interesting but it's the top 25 journals
when you start getting in the fields
that you know like my field I know the
publishing wreck i know some of the
editors I know policies they've changed
and there's some really interesting so
especially in the field of ecology and
evolution with one particular journal so
actually there's there's tons of
journals and I and again this if you
want to show a sort of like if you know
something specific about a field I'd be
interested in hearing what you you have
to say to the explanations of some of
these asteroids that are coming in but
like for example let's say just just
this one there's not as much interesting
in this but let's just collect some of
them click on some of the medical
journals and let's start back again in
1997 and let's watch let's maybe click
on the side so explain this to me for
those that might know these drills and I
really don't know the story there's not
much happening in the late 90s and then
and then in two thousand something that
the journals in medicine something's
happening and I don't know what it is
but it's not you can't you can do this
you can also do this at the article
level you can do all sorts of different
things but the idea again is that there
are powerful new tools out there that we
get not from just our lab that were you
know pulling other people's ideas this
is these are some of these things are
just things that were using from other
technologies to but there there are ways
of looking at this complicated data so
back here so I don't know what my time
is but I'm going to I'd like to jump
into so the data that we have right now
is the Thomson data it's for a footpad
on this stuff it was the cleanest data
set it's the one that people are most
familiar with but we can also apply this
to any data set we're actually working
with lots of other groups to online
archives like ssrn social science
research network at Harvard and we're
lurking with
a little bit with abs and Michael Kurtz
like Johan has been we were talking out
at lunch and then also I mean all sorts
of different different groups so it's
definitely we really aren't in the
business of gathering the data we're in
the business of what's not even business
because we're a science lab view
everything away but we really just want
to develop tools that other people can
use and again this was originally made
for library so it's always fun to talk
to librarians so mapping science I'll
just blast through this because i know
i'm going to went on a time and i want
you want to get to it but this is one
area I'm particularly excited out I've
always been interested in history of
science I've been interested in where
ideas come from what causes births of
fields or disintegration of fields or
what what a fit what caught what
stimulator what was the impetus to some
beautiful experiment that you read about
when you're an undergrad but the idea is
this is the this is the philosophy this
is actually one of the philosophies that
drives a lot of the stuff that we're
doing with ID factors in general the
eigen factor is more the name is
actually a project it's actually it's an
idea kind of and then the actual metric
that's where we use it again so it can
be confusing but it's an idea that
science is about the flow of ideas our
models are representing flow and we use
in networks this is I breath take this
out but since it's here because I
because it's too fun to talk about but
this is a network and this is a way of
representing flow network to represent
flow and this is the blue or Boys and
The Pinker girls and and the links
between them our relationships and and
the idea is that you can look at these
networks and then immediately start to
tell stories again it's just like these
tools looking for ways of telling
stories well being a biologist this is
the stuff I've been dealing with for the
last probably I would say five years
that confusing this is what kind of got
me into eigenvector stuff I was getting
so tired
King at these I was interested in
networks I was interested in applying
some of these powerful tools but this is
what they we were coming up with this is
a yeast protein interaction that what
they're beautiful they're they're
actually something that you'd like to
put up on your wall as a poster but they
don't they're not a tool or not what we
consider a map so the idea is to
simplify and highlight the data and
that's no trivial task compression is is
something that we're always trying to do
in our minds in cartographers are doing
at Google's try everyone's trying to do
this but how do you do it so the idea is
if I was to give you a map and this is a
map of Boston and I was asking you ok
you need to go from the airport to let's
say however how do you get there this is
just too much there's just too much
detail you don't need to see every
Street every every tree every River
every you need something that looks more
like this you need you need what we
consider a map something it's a tool
that you can get around and so this is
kind of what we're doing with the
citation network this actually only
represents right now it's an ugly
picture it's purposely kind of ugly but
it's only represents about five percent
of the citation network that we deal
with it's really ugly well through some
development that Martin Roz balls done
and Carl in the lab there's really only
about four or five s that work on this
stuff and he's done a really nice job of
applying some some advancements in
information there and actually old
concepts and has produced a map of
science so the map of size if we turn
the lights down just a little bit again
if that's all right thanks the circles
here represent the amount of time that
you'd be walking around all the journals
in a particular year this is 2004 on and
the arrows
between them is flow between fields now
this is you can actually zoom in and you
can zoom out you can look just like a
real map you can add detail you can take
detail out student and so you can see
there are some fields that get more
there's more flow between them than
others unfortunately it's still kind of
hard for you to see but there are there
tends to be this trend of applied
science to basic science there's this
flow which is really kind of what kind
of interesting also there's so many
other things that we've had so many
lunch conversations over the map and
things we keep finding we've been
looking at it now for at least six
months and just staring at it looking at
and again zooming in and out and the
really cool thing is that you can
actually do these sorts of things over
time too so the the like the idea that
most people thought that the the science
was a ring well it turns out it's more
of like a new shape based on the
citation data and a lot of people ask us
well how does it come up with the fields
that's the one area of the algorithm the
rest of it's all algorithmically done we
choose those based on the Jew the
journals that we see so this is a
different way of categorizing than
categorizing before instead of
arbitrarily choosing or letting a
journal or however it's decided to cite
a cut cata but we let the citations
deciding we've actually had journals
emails and said actually that's not our
categories daintree crk we're like well
look at your citation patterns and and
that's what that's what the algorithm
came up with okay I'm not going to go
through details but if the mapping stuff
is fun you can zoom into parts like this
is zooming in now at just social
sciences and you start to see some
interesting things for example sociology
breaks into behavioral institutional
sociology you see a lot of the Applied
Sciences popping in from psychology
psychology psychiatry and psychology you
can look at individual fields there's
there's all sorts of things you can do
with the map but it's also a tool so
this is example there's many ways that
we're applying this as a tool and that's
the difference between I think a lot of
the maps that are being created we
right to be a tool just like a regular
map so right here this is an example
with some Holdings from like JSTOR J
sorry as you know is this big repository
it holds a lot of journals though the
yellow is the number of journals that
they hold within science and the purple
stuff they don't have so you can see
they're heavily weighted in economics
and political science and sociology and
areas like this but you can do this for
any sort of holden's you could do it for
your own holdings you can see where
you're missing where you need to add but
you don't do you can do it throughout
all of just science you can actually
apply yours using these algorithms you
can also you can apply them to your own
map if you like to make them all your
own map of your own holdings and look at
these sorts of things so that's one
thing so there's also the interactive
map and again I guess I'll put many of
you maybe you've already seen this but I
might as well show it for those that
haven't seen it this is another okay
okay another example of a tool so if we
go to you can surf around this map
adding detail taking away detail you go
into psychiatry you can see there I
can't see very well screen but you can
you can find first of all all this stuff
again is free of a lever ething I save
on well not everything there's a lot of
the new stuff we haven't put up but a
lot of the things I've been on the web
are all there so you can check these
things but you can go to education only
citing most afloat only comes from
psychiatry but not vice versa so let's
go to education what do we got there yes
psychology is going to psychiatry you
can actually the beautiful thing again
you can add more detail you can look in
more detail like you can with a map and
see what's connected eventually you can
get I'll be able to soon down to
individual papers and do those are
things you can also look at the top
side so again that's a blast through
just some of the tools that we're using
the IPA okay whoa okay come back here
the summary is there is a lot of things
you can do with this these datasets they
are incredibly rich like I said before
there is a wealth of information but
it's not easy to get those things I mean
if you look at in tabular form or you or
you try to trying to make this it's not
an easy and it's continually even with
these tool is going to be hard decisions
to make but but what we do in our lab is
we apply some of the things that we
apply in other fields especially within
biology where we deal with complicated
data sets too and so it's really easily
transferable to the field of busy
metrics plus we have a personal interest
both Karl Bergstrom and Ted Bergstrom
his father I've always had an interest
in the economics of publishing in
journals and so it's been just it's been
a nice sort of synergy to use a clich
but it's been it's been a lot of fun and
most of the fun comes from working with
this group I mean really the reason why
we if we don't think something's fun
we're on to something else and we're
having a lot of fun right now but the
press on the left is called Brooks Trump
he's the he's the main guy he's the p.i
he's probably found a better guide to
work with these he's creative he works
in so many different he's published in
immunology in economics and not bet
everything Ted Bertram he's a guy his
dad is also he
economic economist at the UCSB been
alpha house has been an underground
that's been working with me just
incredibly talented more seffner has
helped do some of the visuals he's in
Germany you've actually been convince in
Seattle a couple weeks were really
excited about that and Martin Roswell
who's been a postdoc we get back on his
physics and he sent a lot of stuff with
network in the field of network sign so
with that I'll in there and thanks for
your attention if there's any questions
I'll be glad to answer
okay I think questions are so maybe
they're here right after it absolutely
so I know yeah no no no no you should
set up so are there any questions why do
I on is setting up just still pondering
or they give too much information or a
lot of a lot of questions good well
these are one I could I'll take one
while because it might change out there
yes yes yes listen very carefully every
same question library that's what I'm so
glad I was I told you to ask some
expressions
researchers status will be strong no
it's a misnomer and we should be careful
about how we write it as mathematicians
we loosely use metaphors and that is a
misnomer or on our part this time in the
model that we're using actually longer
so it's not it's the actual if you were
to jump in this universe of an infinite
walk around the library it's the amount
of time that should be at a job you
obviously can't walk infinitely around
the library but you can think of that
when you think of I'd infected you can
think of if you could do that it would
be the amount of time that you would be
a job so when you're in this other
universe of walking in your library for
infinite and you haven't amount of time
to do this then it would be the amount
of time you spend in a journal if you
were just constantly following citations
family how much time were you out of
ticular article or a particular journal
because as the citations it's a tough
one to grapple your head around but it's
this iterative scheme that also google
uses in in flowing up the rents you get
for websites you're randomly walking
around the internet and then out of your
infinite walk around the internet we say
how much time did you spend CNN how much
time did you spend at the Columbia from
the University Library website you know
how long did you spend at someone's
personal website so that's the idea of
time so it is it's not actual time it's
a time if we use with the metaphor of
innocence reservation frequency just
count how often and how often
one of those random walkers is at a
particular location hey that's the
charger is then use that word yes just
like that's good that's what kind of
answer yes meditation Union guys I
graduated that when I is the impact I am
very clear I I perfectly clear what tool
and because it's known because we're so
used to using impact factor I think
that's another advantage of you have
buffers that people are used to that and
so that's that's that's a drawback right
back here it's new but i think you know
if it gets used it it really is a better
way of evaluating it and I think you
know or other measures light and not
just I do yeah that's a that's a near
perfect introduction to what what we've
been doing at the measure project that
the first couple of slides of stuff that
you already
going to flash them essentially what
measure is trying to do it sits at first
of all it's a research project that is
supported by the mellon Foundation which
has a nuclear weapons lab something very
special and I still don't understand
quite how we were able to make them
fungal research other than that were
very persuasive when it comes to these
matters so it's a project that
investigates sort of the broader
question of how can we measure scholarly
impact thank you get back thread the
focus on a particular metric the focus
is on a whole bunch of networks what are
the kind of ranking state producing
instead of mapping signs mapping the
metrics so we understand that over each
metric needs like the last question was
for example one you can I in fact it
doesn't impact factor you know what were
the eater of the me right it's a problem
of social science that's been investing
social sounds quite a bit because we
talk about it you know when we talk
about matters in the real world we use
these abstract concepts like
intelligence personality in fact do we
don't really know what they mean right
and there's really two approaches to
this problem either you define what it
means right and then and that's what it
is or you actually measure them any way
you look at
many ways in which the thing that you
have a word for could conceive you'd be
measured examine the measurements look
at their correlations and so on and then
the determine some kind of a map of not
just how these measurements relate but
how they relate to the thing that
they're supposed to measure anything Oh
theoretical point you roll insisted in
scholarly assessment I was an assistant
professor for quite a while I can tell
you citation statistics we really do
matter and it's just like Karen's to the
school you know they very often they
don't care about what is being measured
they only care whether a particular
number can be can be handed out and
whether that number looks precise and
look looks trustworthy and both Oh with
that and the reason for the reason why
people love number so much is that it's
just a lot easier to have a number of an
impact chef to read the papers and look
at the file look at the resume that just
worked right and so that's where
citation statistics have come in now I
don't need to talk about the journal
impact factor is a little vibe in here
that sort of visualize it with the
impact factor does it essentially if you
want to if you felt if they published
the impact factor in the year two
thousand and three they're just looking
at two thousand and few citations of
2002 2001 and they divide that by the
number of articles published in those
years for that journal so is that a
correct representation of the impact
factors in measuring now a bit as Jen
said it's a fair approximation of
journal status however it's it's now
used to rank alters themselves and this
is reese strange right because it's a
journal metric it's a nothing that's
supposed to tell us how valuable a
journalist but then woodys university
administrators but they do this well yo
yo honey published in nature so nature's
has a very high impact factor that means
you have a high
faq factor right or that article that
publishes a high impact factor which is
totally bogus because the distribution
of citations to the articles within the
journal is actually very much skewed it
is not under one of those nice symmetric
distributions where you calculate the
mean I may get a good indication of
where that that distribution says no
it's actually very skewed distribution
some articles receive the bulk it's like
the wealth distribution of wealth in the
United States Bill Gates is 15 billion
dollars by the people are dying in the
streets now as the United States well
cleared in Sweden all depends on where
you look at the distribution the same
applies to the journal of nature some
arguments get a lot of citations and
most of them get you know much less the
calculated an average comes a little you
know becomes a little odd you can do the
food journal as a whole perhaps but then
when you start saying well this article
is published in nature therefore it is a
good article you know maybe that one
article got no citations it's actually
being transitive to departments as a
whole like the research assessment
exercise the German mentioned they look
at a whole department entire university
found number citations or the impact
factors whatever they do and then come
up with some ranking of universities of
the film spalding in England right now
regions and nations like stain is made a
very strong push to increase the impact
factor of Spain I've actually seen this
in a favor and it's absolutely true I
know my home country of development for
example it's been the impact factor has
also been very extensively used to
evaluate individual researchers to the
extent that the first thing that they
ask you to fill out is an Excel
spreadsheet you list your 81 papers as
they call them 81 papers of papers that
were published in journals that artifact
by Thomson Reuters and the journal
citation records right all your other
qualifications don't matter in a day
only a one publications right ulysse the
impact factors you some of them all off
in that column and you calculate an
average that's your impact factor it's
too long I presume don't get it from
another promotion too high probably does
not exit
it doesn't really matter in love but
here's here's my my problem with this
this whole this whole setup I think well
we will install the assessment nowadays
it's call me assessment and then if you
know people publish papers that's the
whole idea scientists publish papers and
it published in the Germans so the
article journal article journal is very
easy to well not very easy it's it's a
pivotal thing to extract citation data
from those journal articles and then we
have citation method back factoring the
eigen factory there's a whole bunch of
other proposals out there for example
you can calculate an H investor journals
the whole variety of them right there's
all kinds of issues with that approach
you know and then for well first of all
the ideas that you publish stuff I felt
like a paper record that's cast and soul
I didn't send librarian look at the
citations extract them and it has this
air of inevitability right it's been
printed so it must be true the metrics
of citations of this technique is beyond
the standard out work so I can just
count the number of citations 100
citations is better than 50 citations
everybody understands that as well
symmetrically people say at least I know
what it is so W no effect there's also
kinda kinds of issues though there's a
huge publication delay when you look at
a citation set of six and that violent
publication but it's not just a delay of
publication but it's the delay in going
from from from an idea to the actual
citations in a citation database so I
have an idea right start reading papers
like starting talking ponies right to
pay for six months later and they easily
take a year you're gonna have to get
that paper published right now our only
in phase one now that paper itself has
to be read by some other scientists
right while they're forming guarantee is
then they write a paper then they try to
get it published you look at that entire
cycle easy to four years so we look at
citation data you know the sort of the
bottom end of where this all started
meaning what we're doing is
like looking at a galaxy that's 50
million light years away we're not
seeing that galaxy as it exists today
we're seeing it as it existed 50 million
years ago right it's the same with
citation Davis and when we map science
on the basis of citation data we're not
mapping size and Sciences that exists
today we're mapping signs as it existed
the quarter rock at we're mapping
science as it is indicated by a citation
database in 2004-2005 and those
citations are based on stuff that was
probably several years earlier so
there's there's a huge publication later
there's also a sample size problem in
medicine I know a lot of doctors we
jamin they never publish a paper they
never side in their opinions their
preferences their their view what
matters most are not reported in
citation metrics in terms of resources
the introduction of these kind of
statistics from the literature is
actually quite difficult and i'm not
saying that you know people haven't done
a great job but it's very difficult now
is it since I you know I'm sort of
travel the two generations here you know
I you know I still remember my first
cell phone I actually paid vinyl records
I had a I had one kilobyte a little
computer with a 1 kilobyte randomly when
I was 12 I used to program basic so just
to give you an idea of what generation
on I'm from but what I do see is that
we're in a new paradigm of publishing
and leadership and also in a new
paradigm of how we measure what matters
we're trying to do same thing line
install the assessment but we're now in
the electronic paradigm where most of
the stuff that is being published where
a lot of the stuff is being published
are no
articles that institutional repositories
the prefect multimedia raw data software
operating system databases all of this
stuff is now being published right
images analysis he named it's also being
published in addition to this right now
what we have is a metric that's based on
that's very specific the stuff that is
really that used to be published on
paper but now the digital versions of it
that you still have to you know you have
to pay a subscription to look at it
doesn't work like that now people grout
they read with everyday life they use
whatever they can find and will the
things that they're working at are very
different from this from the Senate
material on top of that when we look at
the kind of metrics of people getting
used to you know that you know I set up
my first Facebook page about a year ago
and in facebook it really doesn't matter
if you know necessarily how many friends
you have but what those friends are
perhaps how many friends they have now
we're going an eigen fire situation
right but it's all but it's dude these
are so this is the ear of social
networking like so the metrics that we
look at the metrics are you know how
many friends do you have how many
citations you have how many figures in
you publish but the metrics are
indicators of trust prestige popularity
and so on there the social network
metrics there's about 15 years of social
network analysis out there that isn't
being used when we look at published
papers published in journals and then we
calculate you know how often things have
been cited honestly I think that's
really you know now that's just not how
things working so that's what measures
been trying to address now how about
usage data is something that we've been
looking at quite intensively right we
know about citation data limitations
first of all the community that you're
measuring impact for is the authors of
jaramana that's essentially what you're
doing because the count citations
artifacts journal articles in the jcr
social science
about 8,500 Germans at this point right
but there's a lot more being published
out there I mean can see that you could
have 30,000 twenty-five thirty thousand
scholarly journals the matter we at
least have one year of publication data
so what we have is this set of Venn
diagrams that become there and then so
on the topic that solid unit is holds a
really big circle the doctors nurses a
whole bunch of people who read things
and are involved in science I dated the
data publish they're not publishing
offers so their views are not reflected
in the journal articles that we measure
citations for couple of years after the
facts and then we calculate them in
backpack that's one specific metric but
when it comes to usage data there's a
lot more interesting things that we can
do first of all everyone's using even
the people who are purveyors are
supposed to be other people's paper
tonight especially when they cite them
so when it comes to the the subset of
the scholarly community that we that we
look at where we measured usage it's a
much bigger subset than just the set of
office when we look at the artifacts
that we can measure usage data for it's
everything anything that has ever been
accessed or download that you can
measure usage data for it's very
different from journal articles right
measuring citations for journal articles
so we have that usage data it actually
pertains to a much broader subset of the
solid and community artifacts that are
out there that say station data ever put
also there's hardly any debate you throw
something in the work will start
downloading it immediately it doesn't
have the past you peer review be
published at citation statistics
correlated once it's on the web or in
any kind of environment people can
access it and that's where your new
sixth day to come from and now on top of
all of that like Jenna has been talking
about these random walks and so on the
one thing with the eigen factor is this
not equity don't get me wrong it's a
random walk you know what people don't
do random box but i'm at the web it's
not a random walk like weeks off online
I'm not
no one is they're not random walk you do
a random walk because you don't know
what people are actually doing so its
assimilation you're forming
dissemination of where people go when
they read stuff right but would usage
that if you know it's the usage data you
know where they go the usage data tells
you but I'd say you don't have to do the
summation of a random or so usage data
is very very promising and we've been
working at it quite a bit so there's
various initiatives that focus on usage
data counters are really good one IRS
sushi that site days doing this so
here's the two things that my talk will
focus on will make it really fab will
focus on the theory too much we're
focused on how can we use usage data
instead of citation data well not
instead of a compliment to our citation
dear and can we explore what kind of
network mattox in addition to the I you
factor in addition to a whole bunch of
other methods typically well we can
calculate from their data and to see
whether we can look at all of these
metrics and whether they tell us
something about what what we are really
talking about when we talk about
scholarly impact and how it does be
measured ok the promise of usage a
overall ok so this is something we've
actually done it well and this is back
in the and the olden days this is when
the the impact factors published
replicate the 2003 and here's what we
did at Los Alamos National Lab before we
measured what people are doing I think
is the link resolving that library
services they still logged just like a
website mom that it record what people
do and rank the journals just by though
their their usage how often is a journal
actually being read the the third column
here is the impact factor for these
journals these are the titles of the
journals so the top five journal
Physical Review Letters general chemical
physics journal of nuclear materials
physical review the internal applied
physics these are a bunch of journals
that matter a lot too
your silence and it's at the loud though
right it's plutonium processing and
building of atom bombs so these journals
matter a lot to these people and the
usage data indicates that the impact
factors of these general don't I mean
look at the spread of you write that
there will not be good ranking if you're
interested in but people artists are
more fun now for the a couple of years
later we've got our hands on a
California State University usage
systems data so the fall to the library
and say yeah we recorded centrally you
can have it and so they ftp that over
and now revamped journalism fortunate
difficult to read the green means that
include good correspondence between the
usage ranking and the impact factor get
jayma science nature journal of the
american academy of child psych
catholics and american journal side
catholic so what you see here is that it
as our dataset expanded so we've been
beyond man when we collected this used
to be the California State University
system our rankings we became much more
some congruent with sort of the general
sense of in fact of the effect factor
represents right so again so the bikini
come becomes larger and our usage
rankings actually converge so that's
what we can do if we increase the scale
of our usage data now with a measure
project will go to that load that we
we've accumulated an incredible amount
of usage data and I think we've got a
good chunk of the world's yearly usage
in our databases I'm perhaps I'm
exaggerating a little but but a good
chunk not anything but a good chunk of
what's going on I'll tell you how we did
that now it measure we did the same
thing to see a lot more green mighty
good science nature penis journal of
biological chemistry so we see that as
we expand the community for which we
report usage data or rankings become
more and more common sense more
what we mean by the impact in general
there's just a show me that usage data
is not random it's actually quite
meaningful and the larger the community
for which you record usage data the more
meaningful it becomes so that that's
something that set us on the path to
measure what I honestly these counting
citations doesn't work very well I think
counting usage doesn't work very well
either again you fall onto the same trap
you just help how often something is the
download well it's very easy for
students to write a pro script and
download his own paper 50,000 times and
then would be rank very highly right so
counting disappoint very well so as if
Jen said it's really good point you want
metrics that are very difficult the
chief okay that's what bait ranks semis
because it uses that entire network so
we were so that's what we're looking at
usage data one and network metrics
second rather than just counting them
and I'm by the way this is not more uses
this is the usage page man which is a
big drink that you can calculate from
usage data that is not based on the
simulation of a random walk with on the
actual walk which you have to usage data
okay the measure project this is our
logo it's a ruler it's pronounced
measured but we we gave it this name so
that the French to call in zoo I really
I hate it when people call it an easy
because that's a that's a Dutch word
that means uh it has a pejorative
connotation so if yours what the measure
project strategy instead of looking at
statistics at fifty citations / 225 no
good we're trying to look at web too for
those social network metrics instead of
just looking at the use of data per
single community we're trying to gather
and collect the world's usage they have
the biggest possible sample that one can
collect usage day before right and then
once we've done that once you collected
all this usage do we calculate a whole
bunch of different metrics we know that
the difference is in
things in our calls view to the
differences in the usage day of the
community for which we recording
situated data but they're actually
qualify the metrics themself and then we
can make a comparison of it the other
things we're not interested in small
scale evaluations you know like a
particular website has a long and they
perform an analysis of it we're looking
at very large scale at this point we
we've already fast at 1 billion usage
events or usage requests threshold and
still growing so the general general
approach here after a very long
introduction which I apologize we we
create a very large scale reference data
set so this is like a basic baseline on
which we perform our research we collect
usage citation of the book graphic data
and combine it into one single database
for all of it is related so for a paper
we know who used it when they used it
what journal that paper appeared in the
citations for the journal and that
articles we have all of us combined in
one single database we collected this
usage data for various communities of
various collections second stage we
investigate sampling issues who really
have a good chunk of the world's usage
is this a good reference database is it
representative we map and characterize
the store looking I'll show you some of
the maps are not as pretty as Jevons but
they're based on usage data we
investigate validity of the usage of
them usage-based metrics and we do that
by the method of cross-validation and
this is something because my background
in psychologists what you do right let's
just say that we're fine and measure
intelligence and some of them some
simple
the rules of golf is really good test
for intelligence believe it or not that
used to be part of intelligence tests in
the 1920s if you didn't know golf you
just found you just don't and I think
that applies to men diversey and the
difficult there that's a good
measurement of intelligence I said well
I'll agree with that I don't go certain
how well someone does it matter right
and then look at whether this correlates
and say well no it doesn't correlate
you're right knowing the rules of golf
doesn't correlate in being good at math
like something's wrong that's cross
validation it means that you may have a
hypothesis about how something can be
measured and then you compare it to
something that supposedly also measures
the same thing if they correlate right
the chances of that are pretty low so
you know the two big message if they
don't call it well actually introduce a
third and a fourth and a fifth and that
is what we're doing in measure give
unique I'll show you some examples of
that anyway this is just a highfalutin
language but we're looking to establish
sort of a scientific basis to talk about
rankings and it's called a scientific
assessment okay let me quickly talk to
you about how we got to see usage data
and then simple answers we asked so we
just called elsevier we called Springer
we called thomson reuters but by the way
they're very very cooperative pardon for
which were quite grateful that they've
done really well for us let seem called
agenta Jace or California State
University system University of
California University of Texas and yes
we did get all of our usage data it was
as simple as setting up an ftp server we
signed some agreements and they have to
feed all of the usage data for the past
five or six years to that server and so
that's how we ended up with about a
billion usage events and I David they
said this one contains about 5 to the
in citations as well so we threw all
that in all of this is an article level
team because we had specific ingredients
that the data that they have to give us
have to be at the article level at the
time stamps on the requests that you
should have to be down to the second we
wanted a request type we wanted a
session identifier and we didn't need
the IP address because that's unreliable
because of proxies and so on you maybe
and that's what they did they give us
this day I still can't believe that
actually worked out took me a year to
collect all that they set the agreement
salt and some partners were a little
more difficult than others but overall
we've got a great collaboration so
here's what we did with talk to
publishers and aggregators about their
usage data we aggregated it ingested it
be duplicated it is the other thing is
when you get to usage data sets right
and they you know they say that article
a is to download and this usage data
they says that article basement download
need to know whether that's the same
article or not so we usually ask for
metadata or unique identifying articles
as well so we've got a huge
deduplication algorithm that are running
that are running on top of the metadata
to decide whether you know two articles
are in fact the same article or not then
we throw this in the reference data said
this can be using a Semantic Web triple
stores they call anyone here know about
triple stores you do very cool
technology has a lot of advantages over
the relational database but also for
relational database back in just just
because it many cases still a little bit
of experimental technology now once we
have that reference data set we map it
out just to see you know what do we have
whether the characteristics what can we
learn from how this data set is
structured and then with you a
mathematic survey at this one will
calculate about 50 different metrics and
we're comparing what
their rankings but they will show you
how that works ok moving on okay so the
data normalization and just I wasn't
going to there's too much the Oliver
data have to have the following fields
you need we wanted unique usage event so
we didn't want statistic so we didn't
want to know from that Journal a is you
download the 50 times no one wanted to
know who downloaded this article at what
time at what date what kind of requested
the issue and was that request issue
within the same session there's another
request so that's why we have a session
identifier in the exception identified
as well then there's a huge difference
with usage statistics now this is what
the David look like this is very messy
we paid to full-time developers because
of the look of the state ingested and
normalize and they did a great job now
the final structure that we end up with
and this is kinda relevant for the other
kind of analysis we're going to do we
can rebuild in touch with extreme users
because instead of session identifier
it's an anonymous session identifier so
we know who the user is we notice the
same user working from the same client
so we know that a user actually went
from document once the document you so
that's what the random welcomes its not
around what we have the wall so it's d1
to d2 session is over somewhat someone
starts a new session goes in documenting
the document for and for each of these
requests that the request type the pipe
and a whole bunch of other details is
one of my abilities okay okay now sign
snapping this is a technique that with
citation data you already have enough
oh no not the duration but you can
calculate that from the clickstream as
well they're looking at the time
differential but it's a date timestamp
yeah it's a good question but you can
calculate how long they actually looked
at the document by looking at the
developers which is very interesting as
well so how do we actually so we're
saying with a citation that citation
data leaks a citation that work ragged
it says so this journal sites this room
you've got a network right but what
usage date is not that simple now most
of you use amazon.com or Netflix you
notice that amazon com when you buy
certain CD it says fifty percent of
people who bought this EP also called
BCD and this hair dryer and this deep
fryer is all right they need to think
that that essentially what we're doing
so we look at these click streams right
in every single click stream is a
session is a set of interactions user
requests like that pertain to a
particular article now since articles
are published in journals right we can
convert each of these sequences to both
article sequences or journalist is
within that session now we do with these
sequences and this is just a simple
markov chain method is that we count the
number of times a journal three was
followed by journal one in those
clickstream the account number of times
that happens right in this case journal
three years followed by a follow journal
22 times right and when we look at these
frequencies we can convert the
probability like so in this case the
probability of someone going from
journal 12 journal three is a 50-percent
like because here's one and here's one
night some student the 10 15 fifty
percent in this case the probability of
someone going from j journal to the
generally is one hundred percent is it's
too over to you they just got paid these
probabilities what you end up with is in
network this is not something we
invented by the way amazon.com
is it netflix uses it everybody knows
about the beer in diapers rule like
supermarkets penis as well no don't when
you need a supermarket people look
actually look at what's in your basket
alright and the things that often
co-occur in shoppers baskets are related
and one of the the anecdotes I know this
is soo severe and diapers are very
strongly related all right I'll have me
guess it why that is it's not because
babies go to the supermarket and buy a
six-pack it's because it's the mother
stayed home and nurse then the father
study the store what they use their buy
diapers and then six right so that's why
you find these kind of relations it's
more or less the same method we can take
the probability that when you have a
user a shopper's basket what is the
probability if I see beer and a basket
adults find dioxide so that's
essentially what we do so once we've
done that we end up with something like
this so this is one of our usage maps
and this is a map that it's actually
difficult to see the edges but this is a
map not so much of the flow of ideas in
science for the map of the action flow
of activity the behavioral flow in the
sciences thank you thank you very much
so each of these dots is a journal and
when there's a connection between the
journal it means that they have a high
frequency oh there's a high frequency
one journal being followed by another
journey right so in this case you get
neuro imaging and this is neuro science
right and what it means is that the line
here means that this journal is very
often very often follows this journal in
the packet patterns that we observe in
our data to produce these beautiful maps
and actually gentleman evan is right i
mean when you look at most people say
you've got a circle of signs that
there's a circle here but it is much
more like it like a hue like au shape
right it's only because this arc here is
is fight is quite enemies but look at
this you gotta science in a champion a
sitting here physics chemistry and
environmental sign
is a whole bunch of Applied Sciences
like healthcare dermatology allergy
asthma sports medicine livestock
nutrition this whole cluster here is
self that conceivably wouldn't find the
citation network because they're the
behavioral atoms of practitioners people
who don't polished your articles but
leave them right and those reading
famines we have so look beautiful things
that I can go on and on just like jevon
said you know we do this every morning
you just look at it and you've got
psychology up here which connects the
cognitive science which connects
education urban studies urban studies
then connects to remote sensing geology
which then connects back to material
sciences connects to physics connects
tremendous in biology and salsa
beautiful beautiful map that tells you
what's going on inside right now right
because this is very recent usage data
instead of looking at citation David we
know what's going on right now and it's
B it's behavioral so it doesn't matter
whether this journal is being cited a
lot a lot of people read it in
conjunction with these journals are
going to be related in this map it seems
of whole bunch of different things that
you can you can well anyway anyone wants
to see these maps are more than happy to
go to detail now here's a citation map
to the same year accident here that
there would be no delay and you can see
this is a much poor math I think in
terms of destruction to begin to
disciplinarian movements that you see
you got it physics chemistry biology
that's it there's no entomology there's
no public health there's no allergy and
asthma there's no urban sensing all that
stuff is gone there's hardly any social
sciences because if you look at the
total body mass citations in the journal
citation records they think the social
sciences represent only five the seven
percent of all citations including the
social science version of the journal
citation record when simply means in the
social science you get a lot more
practitioners and those petitioners
their behavior is recorded in usage data
and it's just half of the of the graph
but it's not a court of insight
you get a very partial to you what's
going on inside now as a premium to the
kind of metrics that we calculated i
usually give this your imaging right has
very few connections in this graph looks
kind of isolated if that journal wasn't
there you would have you would have
disconnected these two branches of the
graph right that's a metric of
importance right now going through what
kind of metric this is but essentially
is being called between us and family
how often does the journal sit on the
paths that connect other journals so in
this case neuroimaging could have a very
low impact factor but it may have a very
high between us in this usage bath and
in the citation graph okay so that
brings us to the metrics that we
calculated I think when you look at
metrics there's really two big classes
that you can look at the first class is
just statistics it's like the
presidential elections right Obama gets
50,000 votes McCain gets 40 9999 votes
Obama and the election right just
counting endorsement as this is our
class of metrics now I think and that's
the web two point oh so there's a whole
bunch important called structural
metrics metrics are based on the
structure of the ground you know where a
particular I'd in this position in the
graph and instruction will determine how
highly ranked it is if you look at the
random walkers here that's page rank
that's the eigenvector there there's a
whole bunch of other ones that I really
like even though I think page rank is
the coolest metric you get shortest path
between the centrality is very very
interesting that closeness centrality
and then a whole bunch of the green
ethics that are actually quite similar
to these metrics over here because they
just helped a number connections that
point to a particular journal here's a
sort of official
tation on how this works so let's look
at the shortest path metrics that you
can get in again this admitted inventors
just standard social network analysis
let's look at the closeness centrality
ashore to staff metrics are based on
calculating the shortest path
connections between pairs of items in
that Network so in this case between in
and out is a shortest path there's many
other paths in this network right they
belong but we can't get mathematically
which of these passes the shoulders back
the closest centrality of a journal is
the average length of the shortest paths
that connect adjourned all other
journals in the network that's lost
innocent family in essence it tells you
if you were to include friend of a
friend of a friend connections how
closes that shown to all other journals
internet doesn't shorter span between us
and Palatine's is my favorite in
actually how often does the journal sit
on the closest on the shortest paths
between all other you know other
journals in the network right what
between us and found indicates is if
that general Jones hide between you some
faculty you take it out it destroys the
graph because you've disrupted already
shortest fast right it's all bit like I
just think you had a terrorist so who
would you want to kill it right this is
the guy with the the hykosan centrality
the highway the guy with the high
betweenness example well the defense of
what kind of damage will inflict on the
network but if you want to disrupt their
communications and their ability to
operate as a cell if you killed the guy
that has the highest between us as well
right there's all kinds of ways to copy
this view it is just a different
different definition
between this example random walk again
what you simulate is just people jumping
randomly from one to the other using the
connections in your network and then
counting how often they end up at a
particular journal particular item in
the network that's it that's paid it
does PageRank bunch that we looked at
income in degree how much how many air
is actually pointed particular item how
many airs point from a particular item
right that's just like accountant
determining the impact factor you can
also look at the information entropy of
the connections if they're weighted so
in this case what you're saying how
promiscuous is that journal or that item
in accepting all kinds of connections
regardless of where they come from in
that Network all right I just say I have
only one connection that connection
happens to be Einstein right that's good
for me right I only have that one
connection I only have that one best
friend that's good for me my entropy
would be low but let us say I have you
know 30,000 friends like OnLive in my
facebook page right but none of them are
very good friends just acquaintances and
they don't matter all that much then my
entity would be very high so entropy is
just a way of working how broad is that
the amount of the amount of influences
on you in that Network so there's a
whole bunch of different metrics that
you can calculate and these metrics we
can calculate now because we've got a
usage map we can cap it for both the
usage graph as well as the citation
graph so we take all these metrics we
calculate to the calculator we're up to
the 2007 version of the JCC on services
in thread and we calculate all of these
metrics and to make it complicated we
gave him code names so if we calculate
it weighed between us between the
centrality on the citation network
oversight dash wbw if we calculated a
page rank on the citation graph that
I've showed you it would be citation now
for the usage graph I showed that usage
now we can do the same thing now get the
same metrics why not so God uses between
us like uses closeness PageRank I'll
degree entropy of degree n degree
entropy weighted page rank so we've got
a whole bunch of them right in total
we're up
about 60 metrics of that at this point
I'm not sure all is ok now in terms of
the just to show you that this does
actually work this is the this is the
page rank this is the the eigenvector
ranking really say that science nature
journal biological chemistry pnas on top
works really well compared to see that
factor by the way it doesn't work so
well using Faraday's is is probably
because we're not looking at it in a
domain-specific sense I also think that
the impact factor Vegas review-journal
everybody sykes a vivir journal right
they excited all the time not because
people care about them but just because
you know because you wanted to provide
some background information so review
journals going to have high impact fact
is there's no escaping that fact page
rank on the other hand that looks at the
total network total network of citations
will actually rank things higher that
are cited by other things that are cited
highly right well in with the impact
factors navigator citations come from
the gap between the centrality look at
how pnas is now at the top that means
it's more interdisciplinary because it's
more often shortest paths connecting all
these different journals closer
centrality same thing in degree
indicating the leds of beautiful
rankings now when it comes to usage our
user tracking I'm merely a 10 x ray so
please don't fall asleep on me just yet
what we need to shut down into close but
that's what it sounds like the door okay
okay it can I have two more minutes you
want two more minutes okay so here the
rankings that we produced offer the
usage network that
look at these these are actually very
much in congruence it should I mean it
demonstrates to you that this does
actually work that usage isn't random
science nature pnas science ATP and
their science nature pnas answer all
right so that they're very good they're
good ranking but here comes the point
about the cross-validation without
actually comparing how all these
rankings correlate and there nothing
about what they need and which of these
we should actually use right and so
that's where a little trip comes in into
the picture that we call a factor
analysis now we can correlate any two
metrics you select the family calculate
the correlation coefficient if you do it
for all pairs of metrics that we
calculate in the end up with the table
like metric eight has a point 68
correlation with metric to give you for
all these methods right now it's very
difficult to find patterns in tables
like that so what we do is we created
math and then that Matthew position each
metric such that its geometrical
distance in that map is commensurate its
correlation so the metrics that are
hiding pointing with them close together
and the metrics that are not strongly
correlated in flipping far apart now the
way that this works is as in keep adding
metrics to this map that Memphis becomes
much more solid right because there's
only that many geometrical positions we
put metric for metric five in this case
right because all of the distances have
to be commensurate to the correlations
that it has with the metrics already map
throw the principal component analysis
now once you've done that okay 10 minute
we end up with a map something like this
and what it does what it does each of
the metrics here is positioned such that
its distances to the other metrics for
sponsor the correlations that we
calculated between the rankings that we
produce so metrics that are close
together produce similar rankings and
methods that are far apart produced
rankings that are very different now
look at this the impact factor is merely
an outlier and its distribution which
means that it's correlations to all of
these other metrics
I mentioned including the eigenvector is
actually pretty large and the usage
metrics are very reliable because they
all want the exact same thing regardless
of how the metric is defined in fact
some of these usage metrics like usage
between us coral a better to their
citation counterparts then either to the
impact factor I'm sorry we're kind of
hating on the impact factor here don't
want to be like that but the truth is
that what this map tells us is that the
impact factor is a measure of stalling
the impact of scientific impact but it's
a very specific metric it produces
rankings that when you compare them to
the rankings of all these other metrics
are kind of like an outline right well
these are the other hand they cluster
very well and they're very close to
these which means that if you combine
all of these together you have a sense
of impact that is much more consensus
sense of impact then you then you would
have with the impact factory but we also
know this by the way if you look at the
actual distribution vertically these are
the degree metrics right and this is
page rank in between this page I can
between is one of the things that they
do they look at the total network
structure so instead of just looking how
many citations you receive they look at
where do those citations felt from and
now they is it how do they position you
in the network so these metrics down
here we look at them as indicating
prestige or power or something like that
up here we just count how many citations
something receives it just popularity
right so is it the folks way of saying
it right is that you've got some bottle
arity metrics up on top here and the
Percy's Matt precision metrics at the
bottom so if you scale it like that and
you look at
what we have really is a mat not just of
these metrics the map of scientific
impact itself and how it could be
measured so if you want to measure
prestige you can choose to do that
either in the basis of citation data or
or a citation it all usage data but if
you want a recent for speed right one
prestige as it is now you want to use
usage data if you want to procedure as
it exists a few years ago with a greater
degree of stability you can use these
methods if you want stuff that is sort
of more specific you can use either of
these methods now actually produce the
new map and the results even more
outspoken we're at some point we nearly
had to remove the impact factor from the
map because it was in such an outline
correlations was just to know so that
being said we haven't explored them
independently in cojida here right so we
got naps because ragged is in this map
right we know what kind of network
secret to come up with to fill the holes
here but we're definitely trying it also
be closer analysis of only going into
that the one thing I do want to show you
very very quickly oh it's this one is
that we're actually working on services
as well although you know clearly that's
not our main objective using
thanks a lot I can't display all of this
in the resolution is quite low but we're
working on something similar to what
Jeff and actually show a show where you
have this is a usage map of science you
can click on any journal that you like
and exports connections in that maps
like for example click on this journal
here it's highlighted together with all
its connections in the graph and what
you're doing when you trace these
connections is that you're really
tracing the actions of millions of users
that have established these connections
like every single edge corresponds to
nearly 200,000 reversals that we
recorded in India in our usage data now
it's two parts of the in the interface
for every journal that you've selected
we produce a scatter plot which is
similar to with Java just showed you you
can choose any metric that you like for
example if you say you're interested in
cited falseness and you want to compare
that to usage a trend right what it will
do is it'll exposition a whole bunch of
journals here the one that I click the
stop with the conservation biology but
American nationalists does really well
on both of these metrics and this little
one here colonial waterbirds doesn't do
so well in either of them right or what
it allows you to do is treat scientific
impact as a multi-dimensional problem
right where you just like intelligence
some people are very good at math well
there's a very different language and we
acknowledge them being smart people just
the same I hope that in the future when
we look at scientific impact and we try
to evaluate in scientific impact means
we know people can go to their being
invoked to their department chairs as
yeah sure my papers on site as much
right but they're read by millions of
CDs worldwide and they're read by people
who read other stuff that does have high
impact factors so all these different
metrics can be used to provide a sort of
much more sort of refined and
multi-dimensional sense of what impact
really means and that's what we're
trying to do with the the measure
project I'm going to click you now I
stolen over those stupid
so in in conclusion I think after one
and a half years a measure we're nearly
at the end of this project I think what
we've done is we created the largest
existing reference date acceptable to
both usage data and citation data we're
still expanding and then looking for
ways to expand it I think it's really
interesting that we can actually map
signs from the viewpoint of users not
from scholarly articles there's a bit of
this look this whole section of that map
that I showed you is not based on what
authors are experts site but what people
actually do even if they'll publish and
I hope that we've defined some kind of a
you know an infrastructure for continued
research program so we're looking for
the collaborations people to come in and
work with us on this data and and do
interesting things and then concludes my
thanks to our fingers thank you for
coming please come down with your
questions and comments and spend some
time with the panelists thank you very
much